hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown is America ready
to fight the coronavirus Republican
senator from Louisiana dr. bill Cassidy
chats with host Lisa Brady about how the
government is responding to the illness
and its impact on the economy also
pathogens specialist dr. Saira Medad
shares her insight on the outbreak and
what actions Americans should and should
not take amid growing concerns country
star John Rich joins host Dave Anthony
to discuss his new fox nation series the
pursuit rich the winner of the fourth
season of Celebrity Apprentice also
opening up about his relationship with
President Trump and how the
commander-in-chief has changed since
hosting the hit reality show
Plus commentary by Fox News Sunday host
Chris Wallace the Fox News rundown is a
Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com i'm shannon bream I'm Tom
shaloo I'm Maria Bartiromo and this is
the Fox News rundown
[Music]
Friday February 28th 2020 and Lisa Brady
keep your hands clean and don't touch
your face
that's a pathogen specialists advice on
protecting yourself from the corona
virus but she also says it's hard to
contain this is you know a respiratory
virus and by its very nature it's
designed to infect as many people as
possible I'm Dave Anthony he's gone from
big and rich and country music to being
part of Fox nation we talked to John
rich about his show the pursuit and why
he's doing it we're not guaranteed
happiness in this country we're
guaranteed the right to pursue happiness
there's a big difference in those two
things and I'm Chris Wallace I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
as coronavirus cases continue to rise
and financial markets fall there is
reassurance from Washington we're ready
we're ready for anything vice president
Mike Penn's telling a conservative
conference on Thursday the health of
Americans is the president's top
priority and the Health and Human
Services Secretary has appealed for calm
we know what we're doing this is what we
do and so I think part of the message to
the American people is we all need to
take a bit of a deep breath here the
government is working on this though
Alyx a czar has also said the US will
probably see more cases California
becoming the first state with a kovat 19
case of unknown origin a patient without
any travel related connections we have
been assured of our capacity to
significantly exponentially increase the
capacity to test and this is something
that again is critical at this moment
California governor Gavin Newsom says
thousands of people are being monitored
worldwide older populations and those
with pre-existing conditions seem to be
at higher risk of severe effects similar
to the flu while there aren't as many
cases involving children but an infected
person doesn't always show symptoms and
when they do those symptoms could be
something else
the corona virus disease has very
similar signs and symptoms to the common
cold to seasonal flu so you know fever
cough shortness of breath this is what
we call influenza like illness
dr. Saira Medad is director of the New
York City health systems special
pathogens program she's also been
featured in the Netflix series pandemic
how to prevent an outbreak so certainly
it is hard to differentiate whether you
know you have just the viral crud
seasonal flu common cold or look for no
virus disease what is good you know
there's a it's like a double-edged sword
so in terms of the good side of the
corona virus disease 80% of the cases
are mild so if you have a mild version
of the corona virus disease then it's
basically it's as if you have the common
cold so those are the symptoms you can
experience but then obviously a subset
of that so about 14% have more severe
disease and then even smaller than that
have a you know a critical stage so in
the beginning obviously it's very hard
to
but if you think you have the
coronavirus disease then certainly let
your healthcare provider know ahead of
time and then you know you know going to
get yourself checked out and tested
right now is one of the best indicators
that it could be coronavirus as opposed
to the flu still travel-related
right now we only have one suspected
case of you know community transmission
and obviously that's in California and
that hasn't even been confirmed yet so
we're waiting for CDC to confirm that so
once this is in the community then it'll
be very hard to distinguish because that
means that individuals won't have a
travel history and then when you have it
they won't have an epidemiological
linkage to help us you know
differentiate we know whether this is
corona virus disease or seasonal flu or
you know the common cold so with that
this is when mitigation strategies will
have to come into play and we're in the
mitigation strategy phase you know as we
speak and this includes social
distancing and this includes obviously
you know cancelling mass gatherings
limiting people basically interacting
with one another and the other way is
just human behavior so letting people
know what to do you know in this type of
situation so again you know you probably
heard it 100 times
so washing your hands them that goes a
long way this is a you know proven
Public Health technique that has worked
for all infectious disease outbreaks for
washing your hands because people touch
their their face almost 20 times in an
hour they don't even know about it and
again this is not of one way of
obviously potentially getting infected
because if you touch an infected surface
area and then you touch your mucus
membranes well that's you know port of
entry
another way of obviously protecting
yourself is you know if you're coughing
or sneezing conference needs in a tissue
or in your elbow and then throw that
tissue away and wash your hands you know
so those are just some very common basic
respiratory you know etiquette that we
want to continue to follow and these
measures go you know again a very long
way and they've proven to actually work
should we be seeing the level of I don't
want to call it panic it's not like
people are running screaming in the
streets but it's there's so much concern
about this ramping up so quickly and yet
as you say something like 80% of the
cases of this are with very mild
symptoms is it just the fear of the
unknown is because because they're so
little we know about this virus so far
that's right and and it's because of the
unknown
is where fear is driving a lot of the
decisions that are being made and this
is not new we actually saw this during
the Ebola outbreak in 2014 I was part of
the Ebola response team in Texas and a
lot of the decisions that were made at
the federal level were based on fear and
politics they were not based on science
unfortunately and if you look at the
Ebola virus disease outbreak in the
United States we only had about 11 cases
but do you remember the furor and hype
that was generated during that time you
know so it's just one of those things
people really need to put things into
context so right now you know this is a
very concerning infectious disease
outbreak we definitely need to stay
informed but but you know at the scale
that we're currently at you know we only
have 60 cases one potential
community-acquired case maybe many more
many more out there we don't know but we
need to rely on the facts and the data
and look at credible sources I know part
of your job is preparing New York City
hospitals for outbreaks
do you know biggest city in the nation
are there enough supplies let's use New
York City as an example to deal with
this I know the California governor said
that they only have you know the number
of testing kits they have for this is
only in the hundreds at this point so
testing is not done at the hospital
level it's done at the Public Health
Laboratory level and that is another
huge issue is this diagnostic testing
capability in the United States and it's
baffling that we don't have this up and
ready you know already this is something
that we should have already scaled up
you know weeks ago and so we need to
make sure that we scale that up to the
appropriate degree and then on top of
that we expand the clinical case
definition of coronavirus disease so
that clinicians if we do suspect this
patient has coronavirus disease we are
able to get the testing done because
right now the approval is only given at
the local health department which
follows CDC recommendations and so we
want to make sure there's a whole
process in place but at the local level
at the healthcare system level you know
certainly there's a lot of preparedness
going around not just here in New York
City but around the nation but dr. Medad
says there have been cuts in recent
years to the money funneled to hospitals
for preparedness Congress is now working
on billions of dollars in emergency
funding for coronavirus response
lives are at stake this is not a time
for name-calling or playing politics
though House Speaker Nancy Pelosi has
criticized the president's funding
proposal as anemic the very fact of
presidents being criticized for not
spending enough of course it's by usual
suspects it shows you that probably we
could spend a little bit more and folks
would not think that it is too much US
Senator Bill Cassidy is a Republican
lawmaker from Louisiana and also a
doctor I'm a big believer you don't
solve problems just by throwing money on
the other hand if they give me clear
indication of why they need the money
where they're spending the money and
there's sufficient oversight I'll be
comfortable
it would probably we'll end up spending
more than 2.5 billion we hope we look
back and say we didn't need to but what
we don't want to do is look back and say
we wish that we had some of the things
that money is being spent on for example
how do we have a faster way to diagnose
now it takes several days we need to if
we need for it to take 20 or 30 minutes
what is the way that if somebody comes
in sick
is there a therapy we can give right
away that will keep them from getting
sicker or is there a drug we can give
that if somebody's exposed before they
get sick we can keep them from getting
ill those are all things that will have
to be done in record time yeah if you
spread it out over time you probably
could spend less money but sometimes you
have to spend a little bit more to get
it done before deadline
what else would billions of dollars from
the federal government be used for
though are we talking about supplies
like more face masks because there seems
to be a shortage worldwide of things
like that right now so a couple things
first yes it would be for personal
protective equipment that would be one
thing that if there is something which
arises you need to have it immediately
available among the group that is dying
at a higher rate and at a younger age in
China or healthcare workers so
the first person to die the doctor who
died at age 32 he was an ophthalmologist
think about it an ophthalmologist
examined someone's eyes an inch from
their nose so the person who's sick is
breathing on them they inhale it and the
doctor gets a bigger load of virus than
the average person would now I'm a
doctor so I hope this doesn't sound
self-serving but you don't want your
health care workers dying because then
there would be no one else to take care
of patients you want your health care
workers to be there to treat everybody
who needs to be treated not they
themselves ending up in a hospital bed
so there will be personal protective
equipment for those who are providing
health care services and others as
needed Florida Democratic congresswoman
Donna shillelagh who served as President
Clinton's Health and Human Services
Secretary says the Trump administration
needs better communication they've got
to speak with one voice and it cannot be
in a political appointee it has to be a
scientist on Wednesday President Trump
put Vice President Mike Pence in charge
of the coronavirus response we're ready
to adapt and we're ready to do whatever
we have to
then on Thursday pence named a White
House response coordinator ambassador
Debbie Burks she is a scientist and a
doctor who's been helping the US
government's role in the fight against
HIV and AIDS but Health and Human
Services chief Alex azar has also
emphasized his role in the coronavirus
response so who is in charge
8th or after the president's press
conference said I am speaking of himself
I'm glad to have vice president pence
I'm the head of the task force and and
you know and as head of a Health and
Human Services beneath him he has CDC
and Barda and NIH and FDA and the other
agencies that have so far been involved
but then he said this is all of
government so if I need to get another
department of government involved there
is no better advocate than
vice-president pence he speaks for the
president he could tell somebody in
another department to collaborate
cooperate with me and there would be no
questions so we can imagine for example
that the Veterans Administration
Hospital
and the Department of Defense are
putting together their own plans a czar
doesn't have any control over the VA or
Department of Defense but Pince does and
so I think this kind of a czar in charge
of Health and Human Services but with
the ability to have the vice president's
help in coordinating with other
departments of the country will work you
know that seems like a pretty good
structure to me the other ripple effects
though are very widespread anything from
you know credit card companies taking a
hit travel tourism restaurants even just
the domino effect of this around the
world also because of supply chains for
other things besides drugs you know
coming from China US companies that have
parts for their products that come from
China for instance all of that has the
potential one would think to have a
significant economic impact and you know
what this does this goes back to your
very first question our billions of
dollars too much to spend I can promise
you that the economic disruption
associated with this will it could
potentially not necessarily potentially
be in the hundreds of billions if we can
somehow prevent that by spending a
little bit more on the front end it's
going to pay for itself many times over
and we hope that if we do spend we'll
look back and say we didn't need to but
we certainly don't want to look back and
say we wish we had not just for the life
and health of people but also for the
economic disruption which oftentimes
contributes greatly to someone's life in
health Louisiana Senator Bill Cassidy
thanks very much for your time thank you
Lisa
[Music]
this is Chris Wallace with your Fox News
commentary
coming up he's the rich half of Big and
Rich a star of country music and now a
member of fox nation that spades good
hey folks it's John rich and welcome to
the pursuit that's his show on the Fox
subscription streaming service that he
even helped promote co-starring in the
ad that ran during the Superbowl we've
got breaking news and we need you on set
right now this is actually the fox
nation greenroom fox nation that's right
cowboy fox nation is the new
entertainment service from the good
folks over at fox news it celebrates
America awesome I always thought if I
was on the Super Bowl and a Super Bowl
commercial would be for something I was
singing we caught up with John Rich
before he goes back out on tour and his
new show the pursuit was of course the
first thing we talked about its stems
from something I've said for a long time
which is we're not guaranteed happiness
in this country we're guaranteed the
right to pursue happiness there's a big
difference than those two things and I
wanted to do a show that did not matter
if you were left writer in the middle
the people I interviewed had one thing
in common we all have the right to
pursue happiness and these people work
very hard and overcame a lot to
accomplish great things in this country
no I know you talked to one or two jud
yep right and so she's a fellow from
star yeah her music and all of that yeah
did you learn anything from her that you
didn't know you know what's interesting
that I'm finding out because I know all
the people that on the show up I've been
around a while I know lots and lots of
interesting people is when you put the
frame of what does the right to pursue
happiness mean to you and you ask
somebody that question man I don't think
they've ever been asked that in an
interview before I know I haven't and so
when they put their story into that
frame they say things with a perspective
that you have not heard before even
people that you've heard a million times
like Wynonna regression Wilson people
like that even I was shocked at some of
the things that they said because it I
think it just uncovers the true nature
of who they are and and what they are as
an
can how they go with their life now
you're not just talking to country
singers right no those are the two I
mentioned early but yeah it's a
inventors athletes veterans there's a
guy named Noah Galloway I go look him up
for a minute he lost his left arm and
left leg in combat in Iraq Wow and is
the only double amputee to ever appear
on the cover of Men's Health magazine I
mean think about that he went ten weeks
into Dancing with the Stars if we got
any fans of that show you remember the
guy with one arm and one leg lifting a
girl up over his head have a really bad
outlook on the world and yeah situation
yeah you know what his outlook was
because I asked him that I said what
were you thinking when you finally woke
up in the hospital and realized you're
missing your left arm and your left leg
and he said one thing that got me
through the depression I went through
was I kept reminding myself that that
explosion was gonna hit somebody and
we've been in situations where we've
said why them why not me well I got the
opportunity for it to be me and I had to
remind myself with that over and over
again to get through that because I had
to say you know what there's a lot of
men that could have handled this but
why'd let them continue doing their job
I was hurt now let me make something of
it I mean what a perspective it was not
many people have that no no not at all
and and and okay so since you've never
been asked it what does it mean for you
the pursuit of happiness well the right
to the right the right to pursue
happiness to me means that I can grow up
in a double-wide trailer in Amarillo
Texas I can be a high school graduate I
cannot have you know a lot of the things
other people may have but I'm not
limited to that it doesn't determine
where I wind up and it's allowed me to
really chase my crazy dreams I mean who
would ever think that a guy could ever
make it in the music business your
parents definitely don't think that no
you know no your family members your
friends they go that's very it's not
only unlikely it ain't gonna happen
learn how to drive a tractor herd cows I
mean so when you were in this
double-wide how did you make it like
what did you how old were you when you
started to try this I started playing
about five or six years old my dad's a
preacher he had four other jobs that he
actually did to make money because it's
a little town and you're just not gonna
make enough money for to pay for four
kids he was a night watchman in a Merlin
National Bank
he sold cars at a Nissan dealership he
gave guitar lessons Holi any slop dogs
Wow on the weekend seat I'd go up my dad
slop hogs feed hogs and so I watched him
working like a maniac hundred hours a
week to make sure we might have had a
used car with a dent in it but guess
what it was the shiniest used car on the
street you know we lived in a
double-wide trailer but it was clean and
immaculate military precision perfect
you know and he taught me hey whatever
you do have take care of what you have
be proud of what you have and always
work to try to do better you know just
just because you started off somewhere
doesn't mean that's where you're gonna
wind up so how does how does how does it
and somebody's soul hard-working like
your dad right and you are a dreamer
hoping to be in the you know a star and
country music yeah I wanted to do I
thought man wouldn't be great if I could
make money doing what actually love to
do my dad loved to preach but he never
made it but that didn't stop and I want
it right then stop him from doing it you
know he worked hard to pay for life
while he still pursued his dream of
being a great minister which he is so
for me man it's all about exhausting
your potential you know I step into
things all the time Fox Nation I never
thought I'm I'm a I'm a TV guy I'm a
songwriter I'm a singer but I do have a
pretty strong perspective on our country
and I know what it means to me and I
feel like there's millions of people
feel the same way well you were a TV guy
I remember was this 2011 when you run
salon 2011 nine years already this was
pre POTUS this is before anyone thought
about trumping the president United
States here is the Celebrity Apprentice
guy The Apprentice guy and you go on
this show yeah well I turned the show
down three times three seasons in a row
because I was a fan of the show and
people look like maniacs on that show
meatloaf but I don't think I want to be
whatever they're doing to people I don't
think I want to put myself of that but
they came to me the fourth time I said
okay you know what I'm gonna give it a
shot I'm gonna play for the kids at st.
Jude Children's Research
hospital directors you all had charities
rabies Children's Hospital in the world
and my goal is a million bucks Piers
Morgan held the record at that point at
like I think half a million bucks I said
well I can't let peers have you know the
top spot I'll see if I can I can up it
and I think having having that on my
mind during the show kept me from acting
like a loony bird kept me from cussing
somebody out I mean I had to add to
break up meatloaf and Gary Busey I'm
killing each other over who stole their
finger paints matter of fact Obama made
fun of Donald Trump at that big presser
that they had that he said Donald Trump
says he wants to be President but really
the biggest decision he's made is how to
get Gary and meatloaf from fighting over
their finger paints as Gary Busey is
wild as he looks like on TV he so I'll
tell you Donald Trump when he was not
the president he goes so John Rich that
was Gary Busey as your project manager
that's not about right now thank you and
I leaned into to him and I said well mr.
Trump Gary is the nicest bunch of guys
I've ever met he he started laughing at
us that's a big statement game and Gary
you're very talented but Gary you're
kind of nuts you're gonna nuts Gary good
people good people kind of nuts so I
think I think the president liked my
sense of humor and saw how hard I was
working and I love st. Jude and at the
end I was able to get to win is that
Donald Trump the same as this Donald
Trump the one we know now in your
opinion yeah I think he is you know off
camera like I remember riding on an
elevator with him and Milani was on the
elevator too and we're going down and he
the belt the guy run in the elevator he
goes has everything going for you and
the guy goes fine mr. Trump and he goes
we keep up the good work you're doing a
great job you know and recognize the guy
and then he he kind of elbows me in the
ribs and tells me a joke which wasn't
very funny I don't think he's a great
joke teller but I made sure I left yeah
we got it yes he's got a good sense of
humor and all that and listen nobody's
perfect obviously but he's got the
results man I mean look at I think the
last poll I saw 70% of Americans
consider the economy good or excellent
at this point and I can tell you I see
that at concerts there's more people
going to concerts he just saw him at a
NASCAR race that thing's sold out
1,000 people you know I remember and 9
10 11 concerts were suffering races you
know people didn't have that extra
incomes right after the the 2008 and you
know meltdown and all that of course in
the recession but the president
you also have seen that he has so many
people who don't like him mm-hmm
and it's so divisive now do you blame
him for any of that well I mean he says
things that are rather divisive from
time to time as result I'm like
everybody else I wish he'd stay off
Twitter as much so you were sometimes
read the tweets and go oh man come on I
think we all feel that way but you ever
talk to him about it yeah I tell the
president all the time get off it to it
no I don't think that's my place to say
that if he asked me I would tell him
that I I don't think he has to say
everything he's thinking okay and he's
probably not can you imagine what all
he's actually thinking that he doesn't
wait well there's an interesting thought
yeah absolutely if you've been in the
Oval Office I have been to the old me
and my wife and I got to go and actually
got a picture standing on either side of
him at the desk but you know you talk
about division in our country when I had
the opportunity on Fox nation to do this
show with the persuit one reason why I
wanted to do it was to show an example
that I can interview somebody who
totally disagrees with me politically
but I respect them and they respect me
because we both work really hard and we
have this one thing in common called the
American dream and the right to pursue
happiness the overarching concept of our
country you know America invented rock
and roll in country music and we're the
ones that invented the light bulb and
we're the ones that invented all these
great things that the world now uses why
is that because we have the right to
pursue happiness the right to exhaust
our potential think of all the billions
of people this very morning that woke up
around the world that have just as much
talent Drive passion intellect as
anybody in America but they're not
allowed to exhaust their potential think
of the music we haven't heard the
medical breakthroughs that haven't
happened the exploration all the things
that humans are capable of they're not
allowed to do that but we are and that's
why it's incumbent on every American to
take advantage of that all right what
are we gonna see you and toured and all
this kind of stuff
well big and rich tour kicks back into
full gear next month
we call it the peace love and happy hour
tour so you can't have more fun than at
Cowboys out there with us this year the
big black rappin cowboy from Dallas my
good friend listen everything is going
great
a lot of music my kids are growing up
well eight and ten-year-old boys it's a
great life and uh I owe all this success
to the Lord number one but America
America that platform gives us all the
right to do what we want to do I urge
everybody to take advantage of it I
catch him on tour as he said starting
next month catch him on Fox Nation with
the show the pursuit John Rich thanks so
much for joining us thank you sir
[Music]
if you're enjoying the Fox News rundown
you can listen every day by going to Fox
News podcast comm and subscribe it there
you will also find exclusive podcast
hosted by some of your favorite Fox News
personalities including Dana Perino Bret
Baier Martha McCallum and Greg Gutfeld
head over to Fox News podcast.com to
listen and subscribe on your favorite
podcast platform it's time for your fox
news commentary wallace what's on your
mind hi this is Chris Wallace anchor of
Fox News Sunday and because I moderated
one of the general election debates in
2016 I'm getting asked a lot about the
moderating of the debate in South
Carolina this week and you know I
respect the people who were on that
stage asking the questions but they kind
of lost control and that's one of the
things that you have to do if you're
moderating a debate and it's hard with
two people it's really hard if you've
got seven but if you don't establish
ground rules very early on they're just
gonna walk all over you and one of the
things I would have said is the next
person who raises their hand I'm not
gonna ask I'm not going to call on you
so you know this isn't third grade
you're not a bunch of kids I'll promise
I'll get to all of you and you know it
wouldn't when people say well how would
you handle it I'd handle it like a dad
with a bunch of kids you know don't make
me go turn around and have to come to
the end of the back of that station
wagon in terms of Sunday we're going to
be talking about it'll be Sunday morning
so we'll know the results in South
Carolina has Bernie Sanders continued
his drive to the nomination has Joe
Biden won a must-win State and where
does it leave us for Super Tuesday and
we'll also have the very latest on the
coronavirus all of that on Fox News
Sunday
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes